autre foyer d'inquiétude la Corée du
Nord qui relance son chantage nucléaire
ce régime dictatorial pourrait profiter
du 5antenire de sa fondation dimanche
pour annoncer qu'il détient l'arme
atomique une façon de faire pression sur
les États-Unis pour obtenir des
garanties sur son avenir sur place le
reportage de Pierre Babet et Éric
Janet avec quelques heures d'avance
pionyang commémore ce que la Corée du
Nord appelle la victoire est-ce que le
Sud nomme plus discrètement et plus
précisément
l'armistice depuis 50 ans kimilsung puis
son fils Kim Jong Hill entretiennent
leur pays dans un véritable état de paix
armé mais beaucoup plus alarmant que ces
simples troupes à pied l'ombre des armes
nucléaires les satellites espions
américains auraient accumulé des indices
tout dernièrement en ligne de mire
yongong la centrale nucléaire déjà
et un autre site récemment
découvert mais au sud les militaires
craignent beaucoup plus les armes
conventionnel que les bombes nucléaires
il est vrai que est apporté de canon du
38e parallèle au centre de la capitale
au ministère de la réunification on
tente d'atténuer les craintes
américaines nous ne sommes pas sû que la
Corée du Nord soit en mesure de produire
des armes de destruction MIVE jusqu'à
présent c'est pourquoi nous avons
demandé à la Corée du Nord d'accepter
des inspections internationale pour
clarifier la possession ou non d'armes
de destruction
massive la guerre de Corée a commencé il
y a 53 ans aujourd'hui pour des raisons
diamétralement opposé Kim Jong Hill et
George Bush font monter la pression de
part et d'autre de ce 38e parallèle là
où l'armistice a figé les belligérants
il y a 50 ans exactement